of the European week of regions and
cities please can I invite you all to
take a seat
and to join us on this fantastic start
of what will be a week of meeting of
exchanging of listening of strengthening
possibly and hopefully also of smiling
to each other because that's where
communication starts with please all
feel welcome maybe before we start a few
practical things to tell you at the same
time we have a listening room so other
people might attend in a listening room
in the silver hall at the same time for
this opening session we have
interpretation in different languages so
with your interpretation device you
could switch to channel one for German
to channel two for English three for
French for for Italian five for Spanish
and six for Polish I'm looking in the
room in the room to see but that seems
to work fine so there will be
interpreters accompanying on us on this
opening session furthermore I would like
to tell you that we have Wi-Fi you can
connect with and we ask of course to
have your phones
silent but not switched off because you
could send us some tweets some comments
some remarks so you can join the
conversation on heart attack
EU regions week with this Wi-Fi with
your cellular phones
let's look into what will be the opening
of this European of regions and cities
we would like to debate and invite a
panel on two main subjects the future of
Europe one subject would be youth
regions and cities an obvious answer to
what does Europe do and the second main
subject is the future of Europe is unity
and cohesion that is also something we
should address and look into with our
panel please let me welcome the two
co-hosts of this event European
Commissioner for regional policy Gauri
nakatsu and president of the European
Committee of the regions Heinz Lambeth
please welcome
[Applause]
and our panelists Vice President of the
European Parliament will take a seat
with them
it is Pavel Tillich
last but not least our guest of honor
the President of the European Commission
mr. jean-claude Juncker
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. younger has two seats but we'll
start with that one
allow me miss keiretsu to invite you for
some opening words thank you very much
first of all mr. president of the
European Commission mr. president of the
European regions mr. vice president's of
European Parliament
welcome to ladies and gentlemen welcome
very warmly welcome to this European
week of regions and cities it's a most
important event for us 6,000 members
representatives of the regions cities
citizens and Jos businesses are here
gathering to speak on what the cohesion
policy has achieved and we had a lot to
say about that but also to speak about
the future because it's the first time
when we meet together after the
Commission submit its proposal for the
next programming period 2021 to 2027
with an amount of 373 billion euro we
secure a question policy which not only
means investments but also European
solidarity at work so welcome once again
I am very grateful to this important
people at a European level that are with
us today to show how close Europe's is
to the citizens and they would like to
be much more closer to the city and
defend this European project because you
know very well better than me that then
it's not business as usual we have to
defend the European projects and
cohesion policy is a most tangible most
visible project most visible life of the
people and I'm coming from Greece I was
last week in Italy I saw in every region
I go rich or poor north or south the
tangible results for you fans who had
improved over the years the life of the
people so I'm looking forward for this
exciting week think once again for being
here today thank you very much
commissioner
so president Lambert's please presidents
ladies and gentlemen it's not by chance
that cohesion policy as a the very
center of this opening meeting of the
European week of cities and regions
cohesion is what holds Europe together
and what you do back home in your
regions in your towns in your local
authorities you do the tangible work
projects things that are done on the
ground day to day in terms of our
European project cohesion policy is not
a policy of the past cohesion policy is
a policy of the future and it's
reassuring to see that more than 8,000
people have signed up to the cohesion
Alliance recently to say that we want to
continue to have a strong cohesion
policy that all the European regions can
be involved in I hope that this week
will be an opportunity for us to go into
more detail with all of these subjects
and also an opportunity for you to
network that's very important of course
all of those who work on developing
Europe you need to meet at least once a
year to network to exchange views to see
how you can do more together rather than
everyone just doing their own thing in
their own corner of Europe it's a it's a
pleasure to have you here as a keynote
speaker can I invite you please to give
us this speech on on the future of
Europe of course
[Applause]
Monsieur de Piedad the president of the
committee of the region's the vice
president of the Parliament I'm
delighted to be here this afternoon I
was told that every time I appear in
public I should say I'm delighted to be
here it's really true but this time I
can tell you it is because we're going
to be talking
I do hope about the future of Europe the
future of our regions cities villages
and the future of the European Union and
all of these are inseparable I have to
say something now I'm here
I've got lights all over the place but I
can't see you so if anybody is inspired
and could focus on the room great now I
can see you all thank you you're
beautiful
do it I have to do it again and again
but English is not the only official
language of the European Union and as
things as they are I will express myself
in French maybe in luxembourgish but by
respect for the public I will
concentrate on the French language
because about 500,000 Luxembourgers
nobody is able to speak Luxembourg but
we had as Luxembourgers to learn the
languages of our neighbors because they
refused to learn ours and so we try to
be as fluent in French as we are fluent
in in German now the Commission which I
preside over launched in 2017 a lengthy
debate on the future of Europe and we
carried out that debate and continued to
carry it out throughout all of Europe
because Europe isn't just Strasbourg or
Brussels Europe is each and every one of
cities and regions I even had the
opportunity to take part in citizen
dialogues the Commission organized a
thousand number a thousand took place in
Freiburg in the Black Forest in Germany
a week ago and the more I take part in
these citizen dialogues the more I
realized that citizens like to be heard
we don't listen to them we don't listen
to them enough they don't listen to us
enough therefore we need to develop
among European citizens or between the
citizens and the institution's ongoing
permanent dialogue including
sometimes tricky explanations in Europe
there
is an increasing number of eurosceptics
skeptics and they tend to be promoting
skeptical opinions but I think we need
to talk to them and I would like to
distinguish between those euro skeptics
who have questions to ask and opinions
to make and also those stupid populist
s' it's not the same thing but I'll say
it here and I've said it elsewhere
we need to distinguish between those
stupid populist s' and also the
nationalists who have an opinion to put
forward on listening to European
citizens from the south north east and
west I realized that citizens who love
Europe or who look kindly upon Europe
would like us to note the fact that they
love their territory their country side
their traditions the diversity that
makes the wealth of Europe and that is
why I say time and again that we can't
conceive of Europe without nations and
territories they're not just an invasion
of history they form part of history and
we shouldn't give the impression that we
want to replace nations with the
European Union nations and the European
Union go hand-in-hand Blaise Pascal said
these things go together nations regions
European Union the three go hand-in-hand
and that's what the task force I
implemented under the presidency or vice
presidency of Timmerman's on
subsidiarity does
the group has issued its report and the
committee of the region's contribute
contributed to it with the assistance of
mr. Lambert's and our colleagues
Schneider and occurred within a few
weeks during the meeting that we're
going to be having in Austria the
Commission needs to take a stance on the
different parts of the report and the
first vice president mr. Timmerman's
will be doing that I won't talk about it
today although I would like to say that
I agree to a large extent with the
comments made by the Bureau of the
committee of the region on the 14th of
September I generally support what was
said by the bureau of the committee of
the regions but above and beyond the
need to deal with the specific nature of
individuals we really need to do more
when it comes to organizing cooperation
and cohesion among ourselves without
cooperation or cohesion economic and
social nothing will be possible in
Europe the European Union is the
virtuous intersection between local
regional national and continental they
all go hand in hand and I'll give you an
example climate change and environmental
transition it's all of Europe in fact
that is involved in that transition it's
not an easy one but it is absolutely
essential individuals want to produce
their own electricity through renewable
energy micro enterprises major
industries place environmental
transition at the heart of their
strategies and European cities have for
a long time being pioneers
of a different way of living the action
of our cities and our urban communities
where 70% of Europeans live is essential
and it's irreplaceable between now and
[Music]
2030 cities are going to be contributing
about a third to co2 emission reductions
in the European Union and I should like
to applaud the remarkable work carried
out by the European Convention of Mayors
which has inspired the rest of the world
and we can be proud of that because now
there is actually a world convention of
Mayors the European Commission is here
to support all of these efforts using
everything available to us so that we
together Europeans succeed in carrying
out that transition towards an
innovative economy which is more
respectful of our planet and also a
source of social progress obviously we
do that through the cohesion policy a
major European solidarity based policy
which will remain and korina Kedah to
has taken that on taking on that
responsibility with a great deal of
talent also for the 2014 to 2020 period
we have allocated 18 billion euros of
structural funds and European investment
to energy efficiency and six billion
euros to renewable energies particularly
in building and housing which represents
40 percent of European energy
consumption furthermore 40 billion euros
from the European Regional Development
Fund were assigned to research and
innovation between now and 2020 this
money should help 15,000 companies to
produce or commercialize new products
support 140,000 startups and create
350,000 jobs also
what was called the plan junker at the
time we don't talk about the Juncker
plan anymore when we launched that plan
it was criticized and it can probably
still be criticized we launched it in
2014 there were people who thought that
the failure of the plan would be
comprehensive it was good the plan
Juncker but since it's not a failure we
mobilized 300 and some 345 billion in
investment now it's called the European
strategic investment fund and not the
plan Juncker anymore but it's exactly
the same thing and it will continue to
be activated when there is a need the
same applies to the European
interconnection mechanism which
contributes to a large extent to the
development of sustainable transport in
our cities and regions with 18 billion
euros already committed for the benefit
of railway navigation sectors this all
shows how present Europe is in regions
and cities close to our citizens even
though sometimes I do regret the fact
that it's not visible enough because
often national leaders make projects
that Acco funded by Europe appear to be
the fruit of their own imagination the
same sometimes applies to the action of
leaders in our regions there are lots of
things in Europe and in our regions our
cities as well that wouldn't have been
possible if the European Union hadn't
lent an active and positive hand to the
development of projects
agreed upon therefore without wanting to
teach any lessons as leaders of cities
and regions and urban communities some
sometimes you need to insist on the fact
that everything that you do is done well
but sometimes you're helped out by the
European Union because that will show
the citizens that Europe is present when
it comes to promoting ideas that you
might have dreamt up that is why we
prepared the budget for 2021 to 2027 and
I would like that European budget and I
know the majority of you don't agree
with it because the cohesion policy
appears to you to be not enough but the
council and the Parliament need to agree
before the European elections in May
2019 because this budget isn't just an
accounting exercise it's the future in
figures and if we look at the financial
prospects for the seven years to come
we're talking about the future we're not
just talking about budgets and
accounting
in this budget which we have recently
submitted the cohesion policy plays a
leading role because the cohesion policy
continues to be important we're
assigning 373 billion euros they will be
invested over the seven years to come in
all of the European regions unlike what
some people asked me I decided together
with Karina not to exclude those regions
that are richer than others from these
funds I don't think that we can penalize
those who death who do better than
others nevertheless those who do do
better than others those who are richer
because the results of the cohesion
policy can be seen perhaps they perform
better they have to understand that
reductions in loans are going to have to
be made I'd also like to say that I read
carefully what you and some other people
say about the cohesion policy regretting
that the amounts are slightly less
between six to ten percent according to
our calculation methods we have a choice
I had a choice
either we don't include in the budget
the new policies we share between all
the needs and therefore we're going to
have to cut or make cuts which will be
seen in the future we've got new
priorities that we're going to have to
include and we're going to have to think
about those migration policies defense
new European policies increased effort
when it comes to research and innovation
more money for young people in Europe
therefore a substantial increase in the
Erasmus programs so either we stick to
what we've got or we include the new
policies for the future
if I had stuck to keeping the old
policies and including the new we would
have about 1.4 percent of the European
GDP in terms of expenditure and even the
European Parliament which tends to be
more ambitious than other institutions
decided to limit the 2021 to 2027 budget
to 1.3 percent so there was no way of
doing two things at the same time to
continue with the policies and add the
new ones now urban development
sustainable Urban Development continues
to be a priority for the Commission six
percent of the envelope of the European
Regional Development Fund will be put
into investment in sustainable Urban
Development because the majority of our
citizens live in an urban setting
therefore we have to focus on that but
don't think that the cohesion policy is
over the cohesion policy economic and
social which was established in the 80s
by the law
is going to be focused on in the coming
decades now you're in Brussels you've
come from all corners of Europe and
often you feel as though you're alone
you've been left alone in your work but
I'd like to tell you that we've been
very careful putting forward our budget
proposals for the future to modernize
the cohesion policy to simplify
administrative tasks to enable local
officials to focus not only on the
formalities but also on the content of
the projects I was a prime minister and
often I abandoned projects that were
co-funded by Europe because sometimes
there was too much administrative burden
so let's be reasonable and let's
cooperate thank you
I see the good wisdom thank you very
much president euchre have a short look
into projects for the future of Europe
let's look at part one the future of
Europe is youth regions and cities
[Music]
[Music]
be part of our journey follow us and
subscribe the road trip projects with
some participants in the room young
people are at the center of the
discussion when we're talking about the
future of Europe to illustrate this we
wanted to invite brilliant and fresh
minds they might be sitting over there I
heard them let me introduce our next
speaker
we have Louisa ganske
Louisa are you there from Germany one of
the young persons that took a road trip
she's right there and lighted this is
Louisa ganske asking a question to
president Juncker
yeah my name is Lisa ASCII and I'm here
with these wonderful people from the
roadtrip project and this project gave
me the opportunity to get a better idea
of what the European Union is doing i
feel that i'm i'm a german citizen and
in my country there's many people who
obviously never had this opportunity to
really understand what europe and what
the european union is doing
and recently there were massive
demonstrations in my country by extreme
right-wing groups and also in other
european countries like sweden or italy
the really extreme right-wing movements
are growing and mr. president I would
really like to know do you feel that
this could endanger the European Union
in the future and what do you think
what's the role of the European Union to
tackle this problem
as he cannot touch ones so your German
are you I was a Viet of fact well I'll
I'll see you in German and thank you for
asking your question in English if not
I'm continuing in English but I prefer
drew there is interpretation into
English from German well Louisa
the question you asked is a question
that noise very much at the center of my
affections because at the European Union
level there is there is interpretation
that we are doing a lot of things on the
level of the European Union and we are
not reaching the ordinary but noble
citizen and so we have to better explain
what you are doing mainly as far as
which the policy and cohesion policy is
concerned that's why I'm so much in
favor of what which committee and
Timmerman's group was preparing to have
regional and local explainers for the
European policy that's highly important
when it comes to this populistic and
nationalistic movements I don't think
that we are well inspired by repeating
what they are saying
I'm always telling representatives of
the traditional political families in
Europe that they should not blindly
follow the populist because they will
publish they will populate the other
morning and the voters are voting in
favor of the original when it comes to
the extreme right we have to stand up
and to say no this is mainly the duty of
those were younger I am we have to say
no to all kind of populism and
nationalism
Thank You president younger Bruna
Tomczyk is is here also she's a young
journalist of the media program youthful
regions media program Bruna please state
your question hello everyone hello mr.
president just kind of quickly the kind
of painted picture so I'm coming from
Croatia I kind of decided
unfortunately leave my country so I've
graduated in the UK the main reason was
because I found kind of lack of
opportunities and I find that there are
so many young and bright people in
Croatia with even higher education and
things like that and still finding so
many different obstacles you know to get
into full-time work and similar so what
kind of what kind of my idea would be
and I'm sure that your opinion does that
already but it is to tackle the youth
unemployment and to really kind of
highlight that it is an important
problem so what kind of just kind of an
overall idea would be is to create an
organisation which would kind of it
would just work in France maybe or not
but because currently it's I believe 24%
around 24 percent of young people are
unemployed so basically it is to give
young people 3 kind of workshops free
skills to invite successful young people
like for example we had with roadtrip
project to create those conferences
where young people could kind of network
and give them different kind of choices
and really kind of be open about that
with universities having those kind of
connections I think it's really
important so yes so creating some sort
of foundation where that could be really
welcomed giving them kind of funding
highlighting that social
entrepreneurship as well
those kind of things I would really like
to kind of stress that that's really
important so I wonder what do you think
about that what do you think but you use
unemployment in general and yes
is that a way to tackle that as well
just two pieces of information the
unemployment the general unemployment
went down to a level we had reached in
2007 so the consequences if the economic
financial and social crisis to some
extent over we have created since 2014
12 million jobs in Europe this is not
the merit of the Commission but had been
lost 12 millions of jobs it would have
been a responsibility of the Commission
youth unemployment went down to a level
we have never experienced since the 2000
so if unemployment is not the big big
tragedy it was two or three years ago
but it remains very high in different
countries of the European Union mainly
in the south of the continent we have
developed the so-called youth county and
we are increasing the positive funds in
the next seven years period for youth
county bring it to levels never
experienced before we have launched
because this is important a so-called
European solidarity cost seventy
thousand young people have registered to
become active wherever help is needed 20
thousands of them on the ground we are
intending to dedicate part of the
structural funds of the European Union
to the fight against youth unemployment
and it will be done and we want to
double the party means dedicated to the
vs plus
program which is a beautiful program we
have in the framework of European Union
till now 10 million young people did
participate to the hospice program by
the way these 10 million young people
till now have produced 1 million of
babies so this is the big liberal
program of the European Commission and
it works and as it works we'll bring the
numbers dedicated to the West most
programs to a higher level by doubling
them and I'm very much in favor of
creating a real network of European
universities to promote exchange between
young people between young entrepreneurs
between dogs were beginning their active
life by creating small enterprises so a
lot of things in the pipe thank you very
much
I see that vice-president allegic I want
to add something it's in detail try to
be a short first of all I need to say
that I feel discriminated and I think
that if the Commission is organizing or
supporting activities like the the tour
of Europe for young people I think that
people my age should also be included no
seriously
now as a serious know that of course was
not seriously meant I think that apart
from what John Torres already said and I
see two sort of sub questions one is
what to do with the extreme right and
populism nationalism and so on well can
I sort of reverse the question you have
to Europe so what exactly are you gonna
be doing how can you help us because I
mean it's not just about the European
Union it's not about the Commission -
your involvement whatever we do we still
a bully encounter situation of politics
which is in crisis in a number of member
states and quite often the national
politicians are hiding behind the
European Union so I think that we need
young people and you ask me or you asked
us about the foundation I think that
whatever you would do after this tour
you would come up with an initiative
with the foundation whatever I'm sure
that we will support
so I think that this can hardly be
tackled without you your own initiative
now in terms of unemployment apart from
what has been said and let's bear in
mind that we have European elections
next year that the next cohesion policy
is yet to be finalized and will be
fine-tuned after the elections you all
young old middle-age whatever age you
have an opportunity to come with your
own input you can try to influence you
can launch ideas you can insert into the
political and public debate a number of
elements and I'm sure that a lot of
those can be picked up but of course a
lot is being done the framework is there
the financial means are available I
think it's also up to your initiative we
can help also these initiatives by
dismantling the burden still I think
there is a lot of burden there's a lot
of obstacles of administrative another
nature but I'm sure that we can tackle
that but I think that look into the
cohesion policy look at what is planned
look for example I'm one of the three
reporters for connecting your facility
and that's my last remark which is over
40 billion program for transport digital
and energy and I think that the one
element that I want to introduce my
strongly much more strongly into the
whole program is the role of regionals
of municipalities that initiatives can
be taken by you and of course young
people have a role to play also in the
regions thank you thank you very much
Ulrika caliphal lundergan is a member of
Kong's Baca Municipal Council and also
Committee of Regents member miss
lundergan please can you add some
comment I like to speak to you younger
almost every young person these days has
already heard the phrase George
generation will end up worse than your
parents the European Union was the
beginning of peace on on our continent
this is the heritage we leave to them
however it is not the only one
unsustainable economy non-inclusive
public governance human rights are a
privilege from review this is also the
heritage that we live for you now let us
look at what is it important for young
people of Europe and let us question us
each and every one is Europe delivering
are we delivering a sustainable Europe
where the air and water and urban space
and that we have clean good food not
being wasted plastic who is produced
used and disposed in a sustainable way
where is the cities where the cities are
green and public transport transport are
affordable and where climate change is
efficiently fourth are we delivering a
Europe of democracy where the decisions
are made at the most appropriate level
and everybody voice is heard where youth
can recognize their voice and their
actions the shape to shape the new world
are we the
bring Europe for all where rules of law
and human rights are not the words on
papers but uncondition allottee
respected where social background and
gender are no factors for how
successfully we are for job markets
where you can feel safe live your life
without being judged and what those who
need help will reach a helping hand are
we delivering it is not too late
we are moving I think in the right
direction but we should not disappoint
the young generation we need to make
sure that you can be proud of what
Europe is and confidence that we chose
right projects tomorrow as they
themselves the younger are our future is
time for Europe to start delivering
thank you very much mrs. lamber granny
let's move on to the reflecting on
European ishutin the future of Europe is
about to placing citizens first and this
is something that was possibly only by
working together with the cities and the
regions to reduce the disparities
between them Europe must concentrate on
delivering economic and social
territorial cohesion to ensure that all
citizens feel a sense of belonging and
benefit from being part of the union
solidarity is the most significant issue
found out from this core reflecting on
Europe initiative let's first watch a
movie about it
I see a future for the EU I don't think
it'll look like it looks like today
don't you see the red with our patch I
think a Fiat equesticles oMG so no group
in Giovanni okay she popped up on Komodo
Laveau chiku credited La Veta reallied
Elinor ET de Navidad posterior
interesting
[Music]
[Music]
the UCD Salafist labienus
Talmud Evancho's may lack capacity no
Breanna risotto Chicago justice social
rocky Islamic resume la la familia de
cámara
oh gee que la señorita professi ala
Basel the Naropa cable llamo aqui
evolving from - Giovanni cheetah Dino
Roper okay Vedek Winn Italian is
objective Oh Monsieur no Sultan is a a
party the Brazil making money a concept
or gesture control or experience le host
a positive in Harappa finanza the
Rebellion's meter radius racial Tonto
competitively lava protection important
Emma Lacovara channel Honda main
corridor
in Esther linear and Austin give a
limited start couldn't be negative and
how unreported soon in a hot area will
see first in thank you sorry that I did
it whooping Demetria another master
because it's never okay political center
okay what about nearly same time was
epic rats you vanish will have on tube
you have a doctor my associate an anchor
store window Pentagon communique and
measure the Laconia bomber you're gonna
get mad
Giovanni acorn or history maja steadily
gently I bear to see a sample Giovanni
simplified or naked Gewehr no no these
are some reactions on the reflecting on
Europe series let's give the microphone
to damn Carbonero whose founder of
calligraphy Anna but also initiator of
reflecting on Europe series in Romania
we are looking how are you I'm here well
putting some light on you thank you
hello everybody
dear friends of our common European path
I'm honored to be here I have dedicated
more than a half of my 20 years of media
experience to developing supporting and
building networks of citizens who
believe in EU and transatlantic values I
found it in 2006 what is now the largest
even transatlantic affairs media
community in Romania it's called
Kalapana our efforts as the main media
partner for unique communication efforts
in Romania are focused on delivering
concepts motivating and ensuring media
coverage in the last two years I
motivated the citizens dialogues
organizing Romania with the presence of
European Commission and the European
Committee of the regions and various EU
commissioners or members of the
Parliament I saw people staying in the
rain in Turkish day or under a strong
Sun in Piatra Neamt debating on mr.
Yonkers white paper proposals for our
common European future last year we
organized local and regional debates
called Agora future of Europe in old
Citadel's rebuilt with European money
from three different historic Romanian
regions hundreds of people came to
debate on the five scenarios for the
future of Europe reposed in mr. Yonkers
white paper event and we engage in
dialogue if local citizens and we voted
a scenario where the locals preferred
and we found out that in Turkish denims
or fur garage the citizens support and
desire more Europe more cohesion and
more solidarity in Bucharest the Royal
Palace was full of more than 500
citizens who wanted their voice to be
heard in the citizens dialogue with the
President of European Commission
and commissioner cradle in in Sibiu mr.
president for sure you could speak next
year in looks and polish because people
will understand you in Bucharest as I
said the palace is full and I met in the
meantime thousands of people all around
the country and I can tell you what
people want people from our cities and
regions
what more cohesion more common action
they want to feel more European
solidarity in cluj-napoca I was together
with Commission on average each in solo
if commissioner katsu and Romania mr.
for European funds I promoted dialogues
if Commissioner outing girl or NGO
coyotes and I can tell you that people
were so interested about common future
asking concrete and various questions on
economy security education or European
funds I am sure that you your excellency
president Lambert remember the message
you received in Bucharest where you had
the reflecting on Europe dialogue to Get
Rid Commissioner crit so I was there as
moderator as well and it was a great
opportunity to talk about cohesion and
solidarity with mr. Marko markula the
former president of the committee Ridge
of regions and one of the best time and
may mayors Emil Bock who presented the
views in Transylvania last year in
another great reflecting on Europe local
dialogue we are in the middle of a
series of local events organized for the
committee of regions in Bacau elf of
Sibiu Cruz napoca and Arad and maybe
there will be more local regional events
because we started this campaign ahead
of the EU local and regional authority
summit organised in Bucharest in March
next year during the Romanian presidency
of the new council we debated on the
future of Europe and the vision of young
generation in Bacau about integrated
solutions of regional development in
metropolitan areas like in Bucharest in
fove
and we talked we will talk about new
technologies labor force and sustainable
development or local engagement for the
future of Europe in Sibiu the best thing
for me and my team from Kalapana is that
we have the unique chance to promote
European values in such a diverse
institutional and national team European
Parliament European Commission European
Committees of regions we have German
Italian Spanish French Greek British
Austin and many other friends and
work together dear European friends our
citizens were more Europe and the better
one
it is so false to say that is hard to
connect our citizens to our common
values I saw and I listened and I lived
great moments in the local dialogues
that I moderated on European topics and
I am sure that we only have to
understand the importance of
communication with our citizens from
every city from every region from every
village if European institutions stand
together in very public communication if
local authorities and national
governments connect themselves our
people will connect to Europe as
president of European Committee of
regions I would strongly support the
joint new communication by the European
institutions to which regions and cities
will connect since the regions and
cities are the direct link with the
citizens our people will connect my
cells to Europe it's an active part of
the solutions reconnecting our citizens
for regions and cities is crucial
president Lambert what do you think of
this idea Thank You mr. Kavanagh you
would be a very good president of the
committee of the regions you're quite
right and I remember that dialogue the
citizens dialog in Bucharest we need to
reconnect European citizens to the
European Union we need to reconnect
their hearts minds and stomachs let's
not forget their hearts I think there's
a kind of magic triangle on the one hand
we need to talk more about the European
Union's success stories not just the
problems but the successes as well all
that we've done together
Europe the nation-states and the regions
we need to make sure that citizens can
see the added value of the European
Union when they travel with the euro I
needed four different currencies in my
pocket when I was a young person also
for instance the issue of
the costs roaming costs that are now
abolished a metro for instance if
someone gets on the metro that's been
co-funded with European France and then
also the commitment of local and
regional politicians I think they play a
crucial role in the European Union you
can't just say what people want locally
and make that happen at the European
level we have to try and anchor this in
stone and to monitor the results that
come out of this kind of dialogue we
need to do a lot more and I hope that we
can do this work together I would like
to give the word to member of the
Flemish Parliament Carl von laue who is
also committee of regions member crema -
good afternoon their European friends on
behalf of my group the European alliance
I would like to welcome president
younger commissioner Cato and also you
be vice president shell chica with
European elections looming we are really
at a turning point making European Union
a stronger global actor in the world
speaking with all with one single voice
it all sounds very nice in words but let
us be down-to-earth European Union is a
house that needs to have solid bases
anchored to the locals and citizens
needs European Union will be soon with
27 member states and brexit tells us
it's all urgent to protect European
Union we note an increasing level of
centralization at EU and even central
governments the subsidiarity principle
seems to be applied only as far as the
member state level even worse in some
case central governments
suppressed powers autonomy and freedom
of sub-national governments and their
elected representatives brexit hard or
soft will produce negative effects
across European Union and will hit
several European Union nations and
regions who have closed economy and
trade ties with UK how do we address
this situation we need to move quickly
to the implementation of the
recommendations of the task force on
subsidiarity we need mechanisms enabling
regions especially those with
legislative powers to participate across
the whole legislative cycle we need to
think to the impact of brexit and
regions in cities in particularly port
cities and embed invadin veget offending
support schemes to compensate for the
negative economic and social effects and
we also need to ensure common values
respect of democracy and basic freedoms
who are guaranteed across the board in
European Union without distinction let
me conclude their friends to say that in
this respect it's a shame that in Europe
there are again political prisoners and
democratically elected leaders in exile
who cannot return home simply because
they have acted in accordance with their
people wish and aspirations thank you
thank you for your contribution mr.
vanlowe
let's give the word also to mr. Shyam
Betty Roberto president of the Veneto
Regional Council and also committee of
regions member
that's it thank you very much
on behalf of my group for the ECR I'd
like to request a stronger system of
governance a bottom-up system we can't
talk about local and regional
governments just as consultants we need
greater closeness for decisions we need
involvement of the local authorities to
enable us to govern independently to
foresee interventions from higher levels
only when absolutely necessary European
history is made up of cities and regions
in history we see all different regions
Flanders Normandy Andalusia Corsica
burgundy material the Veneto and so on
can you imagine Europe without the
history of the Republic of Venice I
can't to construct Europe we have to go
back to our roots we have to invest in
the regions that is in the institutions
that are closer to the citizens we need
to see the principle of subsidiarity one
of the greatest pillars that has been
forgotten by the Union regions
instruments of democracy that can think
globally look at major global processes
but also act locally they can choose the
best strategies that are the best
adapted to local realities the Venator
has different needs
compared to different regions and we
need to provide a response to the
demands of our own citizens and local
authorities regional policies actually
brought about major results in community
cohesion as Jacque dolor saw the task
force for subsidiarity and
proportionality was an interesting and
important initiative for the president
of the Commission but I'd like to say
that we think that the legislation of
the European Union has to respect in a
more coherent
the principles of subsidiarity and
proportionality and it needs to be
legislatively less dense leaving greater
freedom of action to the regional and
local authorities given that the role of
cities and regions is crucial when we're
talking about acting and implementing
European legislation in the territories
we need to guarantee that our points of
view are really taken into account and
then reflected in the institutional
framework of the European Union now as
for elected representatives and we have
all been elected by our citizens
directly we represent the committee of
the region's but we think that we need
to draw up specific proposals to
increase the participation of regional
officials in decision-making processes
on an EU level I think it's absolutely
essential to think about a greater role
on on the part of the authorities
guaranteeing greater participation when
it comes to defining strategic
priorities for European policies we
think that greater involvement of local
and regional authorities in
decision-making processes in Europe is
crucial to regain the trust of our
citizens in the European Union thank you
thank you mr. giambetti I would like to
invite the whole panel to reflect let's
start with President Juncker some
closing words on the above
oui madame well many things have been
said and it's difficult to pick out
aspects to prioritize what I wanted to
say first of all is that subsidiarity in
my opinion it's not a dirty a dirty word
or something that means nothing
lots of the problems that have arisen
due to the implementation of
subsidiarity have seen different
responses at the national level
some may have the perception that the
European Union is the Commission and it
is trying to bring in excessive
centralization I think that those on the
ground are the ones that have to manage
the things in their local areas mayors
local councillors regional or their
authorities commissioners don't have
enough knowledge of what's going on on
the ground to dictate rules that would
seat everyone I think that the level
that is closest to the citizens is the
one that needs to decide on what cities
and regions or States can do or where
these stakeholders cannot act that's
where the Union needs that act that is
why we said that the the European Union
should be big on big things than small
and small things at the beginning of our
term of office
there were 120 130 initiatives a year
launched by the previous Commission but
we wanted some 2223 initiatives for year
we canceled legislative initiatives that
didn't make sense and which no longer
and we repealed those that didn't suit
the reality on the ground so that's the
principle here there we have to have
policies that can be implemented at the
national level but what I wanted it add
that sometimes I have the impression
when we say subsidiarity we mean perhaps
the opposite of solidarity solidarity
should not be replaced by subsidiarity
they go together some parts of policy
need to be European part public policy
because nation-states don't have enough
resources to act alone Galileo for
instance we've launched 26 satellites
not one single member state of the
European Union could launch 26 satellite
satellite and we need 30 for the system
that we're setting up to operate 400
million consumers and users are already
benefiting from the Galileo system
plastics we heard about plastics
there would be no unilateral or national
action that could deal with this problem
a few months ago the Commission launched
a major plan to fight against plastic
pollution in the oceans and only Europe
can do that really so with policy we
have to have this kind of approach not
one single country can do this on its
own or do it better
for instance if we're working with
Africa and you can't do everything at
the same time as well you can't overload
the European but vote in the European
citizens dialogue or dialogues that we
were that we had we were told the Europe
deals with everything but Europe should
not deal with absolutely every last
detail there needs to be more patience
as well in Europe and more determination
these are long journeys and you can't
complete these journeys without patience
and determination
vice president tillage can give you the
opportunity to comment on the
contributions moderator first of all I
feel from a number of the statements and
not just here today very critical tone
towards the European Union and it needs
to be said that yes we do have
difficulties we do have challenges we
are not always on time up with solutions
we might not be always entirely
efficient and a number of initiatives
are blocked in fact especially in the
body which has not been mentioned today
and the European Council in the council
that's where we have problems the
inability to agree to find a compromise
to give up certain sensitivities or
issues that might be sensitive but I
need to say that Europe whether it's 70
80 85 90 percent I don't know it's
difficult to denominate but works very
well but we just take it for granted I
think that we would have time just to go
into a number of areas we would show
that it is with us
on daily basis everywhere it is what the
European Union brought it is in perfect
it has semi maybe a certain fragility
but it's there but we take it for
granted and on the background of that
we've got the problems the issues that
not necessarily we have managed lately
to tackle now it has been said that the
European Union needs protection no I
believe that the European Union needs
development it needs to tackle the
issues we need to put the real issues on
the table and to see what the
alternative solutions are to generate
certain energy to have the political
courage to take a decision and to be
able to sell it at home well maybe I as
a politician have created an environment
in which might not be well accepted this
is what we need to do if we develop if
we tackle the issues that are of really
interest to to people whether younger or
older
we will deliver that will be again
appreciated and that is in fact the
protection you now it has all been also
set what implications there will be with
breaks it yes correct
there will be implications but the
European communities allow me to be a
bit blunt were before the UK's
membership and it will be the European
Union will be also after eventually the
UK will leave there will be implications
but I think that again this can be dealt
with and we've got issues of our own
that we need to tackle subsidiarity
Veneto one of my favourite regions I'm
there nearly nearly every week but let
me maybe say both on this and also
visibly too or young people you know
when Europe will be even closer to not
to per perfectionism but will be one
level up I would love to see these young
people that did the tour of Europe
representing here today today and
tomorrow the committee of regions why
are the young people not running for
elections some municipal original
actions while they not delegated into
the committee of regions why in fact if
I look around the youth the young people
are in minority why do we have a
representative of the committee of
regions saying that we are insufficient
in terms of subsidiarity why at the same
time your other of your colleagues never
came to me never raised a single
concrete piece of legislation saying we
have a problem there with subsidiarity
this is something that we can do better
yes your reporters on files on which I
were come not always not always with a
well elaborated paper not always with a
lot of arguments and substance but they
do come but all of you can come young
people can come we can enter enter into
an institutional dialogue in a different
way than through just papers how many of
the of the contribution today were a
long speeches why we have not single out
three four key points key messages one
wanted to leave with the representatives
of the European Commission of the
European Parliament that we
can concretely tackle so we can all do
better including of course we in the
Parliament and myself but there a lot
that we men mention that we have also
mentioned here today in fact I mean
we've got forums we've got means to deal
with it and the question is and I with
all due respect to subsidiarity I'm very
much a subsidiarity person I'm very much
do dealing with issues where it really
matters where it discloses where we can
be decisive efficient but we've got a
number of other issues I mean to tackle
and there are ways so that would be
maybe my invitation to conclude with
every single of us regardless of age
professional regional let's say
allocation we we can still deliver we
we've got issues to tackle we we can do
better
but I think that we just need to if we
want the European Union to function
better and on subsidiarity principle
then we have to be much less formal much
more informal and focusing on on the
real issues and not politicizing so I'm
sorry that I was probably with that last
statement I was not too popular with
some of you but I think that this is how
you can do politics you can do it in a
way where you deliver or you can be you
can be popular so well let's also make
that choice among ourselves thank you
thank you vice presidental ichika let me
give the word to Commission a keiretsu
thank you very much for me it was very
interesting as always to hear about
things that are so important for us on
young people regions and cities you know
very well that the regions and cities
are the most important partners for us
and they are you are inspiring us
everywhere I go if I look only at the
first row we have worked so hard with
Italy to help after the remote after the
earthquake with Scottish amorini and we
are proud that we have contributed to 1
billion euro to these regions so much
affected in Vilonia for instance we had
this
caterpillar case last year and we are
also very happy and proud that we have
helped
I see also our friends from Greece I
just come from Greece and I'm everytime
so much inspired by the mayor's regions
who are facing this problem problem of
migrants are doing so much things for
for for the people so we don't have this
arrogance that we know from Brussels or
from even from the Capitals what is
needed from the regions we know that you
have to have a say about what is needed
in the ridges because you know better
than us you know better your regions
Croatia young lady who had this
opportunity I would say to live and work
and learn in another country but in in
the UK but in another the other part of
the coin is that Croatia remains without
wood so wise brain like you have so I
was two weeks ago in Croatia and not
only in Zagreb but also in Vukovar which
was so much affected by the world and we
made a plan after the post war to
encourage young people like you to come
back in Croatia and work in German is
the same we are doing what we we are
saying here cross-border cooperation
small and medium-sized enterprises it's
very emotional for me to see people from
the Frankfurt a mother for instance and
schloop it's a coming and working
together after years and years and
decades when so many people had died
over these important
borders in the freedom on the search of
freedom and better life so yes I agree
we take so many things for granted mr.
president so spoke about
Erasmus and other things which were
impossible to think about 28 30 years
ago I really think that we need young
people I am delighted and proud that
this is a youngest European forum
four young people will be everywhere
because you you need you your ideas your
energy your enthusiasm we have to defend
these European projects because we have
to ask ourselves not what we did with
this European project but what we leave
for the next generation
if we will not have European projects
thank you very much thank you madam
commissioner president Lambert's yes
there are things that don't work well in
Europe but also you need to look at what
does work well if we want to progress we
have to have dialogue we have to discuss
things but we also have to act that's
the important thing
all of those who are here presenting
projects
here there and everywhere in Europe but
they act everyday that's what we need to
work on that's what we need to develop
yes we can be frustrated vice president
when we look at what's happening around
the question of subsidiarity we don't
discuss things enough all of that but
with the task force with the nine
recommendations and the 16 concrete
actions I think that shows the road that
we need to go down as you said we need
to speak seriously about the details and
set priorities Europe should not deal
with every single detail as president
Juncker
quite rightly reminded us can do
important things it is important it has
a big future in front of it the European
Union it has problems but above all it
has a destiny a great destiny and I
wanted to reiterate what President
Kennedy said once you shouldn't ask what
Europe can do for me and don't be angry
when things aren't perfect but ask
yourselves what can I do for Europe and
I think we can all do a great deal thank
you very much president Lambert's before
we pass to
our second part the future of Europe is
unity and cohesion I would like to
wonder and ask the question if there
still is some time for you to stay mr.
president because I know that you have a
very busy schedule and I don't know if
it still is possible to keep you here
since the time is flowing javelin toss
shorter I was intending to stay but if
you want I can I can me well but I've
heard I do need to actually get going
but miss Kurtz who will stay in my place
I do have to get going
thank you very much for being here
[Applause]
so let's address the you challenges
through cohesion policy the future of
Europe is unity and cohesion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
see if I have light to read this okay
thank you very much
quoting mr. Ortega y Gasset I am me my
circumstances these are mine
I was born in Algeciras at the region of
Andalusia Spain my city is located
located in a strategic geographical
point for being in the Strait of
Gibraltar
at this point the distance between
Europe and Africa is only 14 kilometers
of ocean in my city we are living very
directly two of the major challenges
that Europe is currently facing
migration and breaks it I am working for
25 years at the innovation and
development agency of Andalusia which
has been the intermediate body since
1991 of five consecutive global grants
funded by the European Regional
Development Fund I have seen along these
years the determining contribution of
European funds making of innovation and
economic driving force for the social
economic and territorial cohesion
reflecting on the future of Europe I
believe that there is no better Europe
without more Europe and to this purpose
we need a strong cohesion policy
post-2020 closer the neighbor to
citizens dear Commissioner dear
president Lombardi our vice-president
tanishka all together we need to bring
Europe closer to the hearts of the
citizens and there is no better way to
do so than by places citizens at the
heart of cohesion policy as
vice-president of the European
Parliament I would play citizens at the
heart of the research and innovation
priorities of cohesion policy by offer
Citizens effective means of
participation in the innovation
governance system boosting social impact
investing in LGI projects promoting
social innovation to solve societal
challenges and communicating properly
what cohesion policy support delivers
for the improvement of living conditions
of citizens vice-president Eliska but
you be ready to support these ideas for
the cohesion policy post 2020 thank you
very much
I think that in broad terms of what you
have presented is good music I'm sure to
our ears but the devil lies in the
details and I think that that would have
to be let's celebrate it but let's start
with a current situation and I think
that that will give you also an implicit
if not explicit answer as it is
absolutely clear we are now already in
the let's say initial phases of setting
up negotiating and in the future
adopting the multi-annual financial
framework that of course means we are
looking at how the EU policies you fund
it policies will be looking like in the
next financial period cohesion policy
has been mentioned today numerous times
and it is clearly the policy that one
should focus on what is the current
environment and that also has to be
noted the current environment but
Commission might prove me eventually
wrong is that not everyone in the
council so not every single member state
is of the opinion that more should be
spent on cohesion policy in the future
so what savings and and costs let's say
balance are wanting and and rather let's
say the political perception of looking
at it may prevail my may prevail in
negative terms so that's already were
you regions
have a role to play you are the
beneficiaries of that policy the
entities which are located in your
regions you know best of all of us how
cohesion policy has worked out for you
or eventually in what respect
has it been deficient so that is one
issue I mean putting a clear messaging
or sending clear messaging putting
pressure also on the authorities of your
own member states to understand what is
the expectation secondly and I've
already referred to that the European
elections are coming in some mistakes we
have reasonably high turnout in some a
relatively low turnout but regardless of
the situation we need to say that in a
number of member states the current
political representation is quite often
not sufficiently able to put on the
table the real issues I'm sure that
we've got a number of problems I mean
migration has been also referred to
today but we do see certain member
states were one or two topics dominate
but dominate in a negative way so I
think that we need to have a positive
agenda we need to know what we want what
we expect cohesion policy is not an
objective but it is a policy that should
deliver should with which we should
reach the objectives so it starts by
setting the objectives right and of
course the Commission is subtly
instrumental in this respect of course
the Parliament has a role to play and
national authorities but again it is
also the region's weather here in
Brussels or in the individual member
states to play a role citizens that we
have referred to again we should not be
prescribing how citizens should be
involved but yes I would definitely
support it and let's see what the
options are if you would go today to the
year in Parliament you would see a booth
there which would show what we have
managed in the last five years to
deliver on and I would say dominantly in
let's say the area that we could with a
little bit of simplification call call
cohesion we also would like to see
people active in the election campaign
so it's not just somewhere in certain
paid and a few ideas but that we would
have a turnout and that we would have
people that would come to the elections
but before that would engage themselves
in debate what are the topical issues
for them citizens for the regions and of
course what is expected to be the let's
see note the the turnout in terms of
numbers but what should come out of it
what should the policy look like it
should not be just as it has been set
let's say going just from the top but
bottom-up approach and what you have
referred to is one of the options it
might be difficult to implement some
where it might be more easier to
implement somewhere else but I'm glad to
see that there is someone that comes
with initiative and says this is what we
would see it like or if I may return to
the lady from Croatia that is and I
can't be critical of you my kids also
were educated abroad and they also live
live abroad but I think that you again
have a role to play if you say
unemployment high you have the education
you have the ability you have the
connections you have got the context you
have the networks and now you will also
see what the Keynesian policies to be
focusing on there are concrete
opportunities that's why we should be
focusing also on young people but on
startups on new businesses but and
that's my last remark entrepreneurship
we have spoken a lot about solidarity I
would add responsibility and I would
also say what we are losing on in the
opinion today the ability to go into a
race and the entrepreneurship skills and
there of course cohesion policy also has
old play I do apologize but a majority
just would like to say that in six
minutes I will have to leave because at
half past I have my files on which I'm a
reporter in the Transport Committee
thank you okay
thank you very much let's add a comment
of mashes million over from social
platform yes good afternoon it's an
honor to be here as a civil society
representatives so we stand for 49
umbrella organizations on new level
working in the social sector we of
course see the benefits of coefficient
cohesion policy in a very concrete way
especially we witness that by investing
in people and in communities cohesion
policy promotes social investments which
are productive and that have high
returns for societies as a whole such as
investing in early childhood training
education accessible and affordable
services this is why we think that those
efforts need to be scaled up and this is
why a strong cohesion policy needs to be
at the heart of the European future and
the heart of the next multi-annual
financial framework the facts on the
ground actually speak for themselves let
me just tell you one despite the recent
economic recovery Europe is facing
considerable challenges such a
persisting territorial disparities that
actually linked with social inequalities
between but also within countries and
regions and still 118 million of people
in Europe live at the risk of poverty
and social exclusion which is even below
the figure that we had in 2008 at the
onset of the global financial crisis and
we know and also many financial
institutions have said that that
inequalities actually inhibit inclusive
economic growth and societal cohesion
however I would like to look at the
glass more as half-full as rather as
health empty and Europe has now a unique
opportunity to tackle social divergences
promote equal opportunities social
inclusion and upward convergence this
instrument is called the European peel
of social rights which was proclaimed by
all heads of government at the
guttenberg summit last year and together
with the United Nations sustainable
development goals which put the pledge
of leaving no one behind at the center
of policymaking the pillar and
implementing the social pillar requires
very concrete action not only by the UN
member states but also by local inter
authorities social partners and civil
society we think that it is now the time
to translate those initiatives into
concrete actions on the ground and for
us it would be a very visible way how
the European Union can take better care
of its social dimension this is why in
our opinion a genuine commitment to a
more social inclusive and sustainable
Europe requires a strong cohesion policy
which accessible which is accessible to
all regions and territories so I address
my question also to Vice President
Alicia but I think we can also enlarge
the scope since you have to live and you
were asking for concrete proposals so we
would prioritize investing in people and
communities by aligning cohesion policy
with the social objectives and the
principles enshrined in the pillar in
the European pillar of social rights and
we also think that it is an important to
support the implementation of the
sustainable development goals which can
drive a future progressive European
agenda at local and regional levels and
actually leverage complementary benefits
of Economic Development well-being of
people and the protection of our
environment and finally we think that
promoting cross-sectoral partnerships
with a strong participation of civil
society in the implementation and
planning in the Malaysian phase of all
cohesion policy programs is crucially
important the vice president would you
be able to support those proposals for
cohesion policy post-2020 thank you very
much supporter to look like how would
you imagine this support to look like
well we think that now in the very
critical negotiation process that are
going on that I think it would be it
would be very beneficial that our voices
the voices of civil society the voices
of civil society organizations are heard
the voices of youth I heard when it
comes to actually the future of Europe
in terms of making it more sustainable
and prosperous call it citizen and
actually tackling inequalities I
need to say that your voice is quite
loud which is positive it's well heard
about in addition to that I would say
come and see me and we can see how we
can let's say take the elements in a
concrete way further what are the the
areas what are the issues how we could
integrate these elements I'm sure that
we are tackling it basically with every
single legislation in a certain way now
for example I've been going through
1,500 amendments to my draft report and
a colleague of mine on the connecting
Europe facility and you would see
several dozens that deal exactly with
the issue and we will build a solid
compromise amendment to be voted on in
this respect but I'm happy if you come
and see me and we care we can let's say
go deeper on on the issue but otherwise
I think whatever you have said is it's
something that is well reflected I very
well understand I would even say that if
we get the the policy right in terms of
focus the cohesion policy we do the
cross-sectoral approach that you have
spoken of which for example in inset
also I am trying to do with energy and
with digital so that we don't have
transport just transport that digital
transport that we have ancillary
activities in favor of energy etc etc
and I think that we should be looking at
all the new policies in the same way I
mean it has to be basically a good
policymaking means that we would be
penetrating the individual policies and
basically complain making the
complementary but also in terms of
financial terms I think that blending
will definitely help and it will also
encourage businesses to to go to go
ahead but on the concrete issues that
you have mentioned it's just sort of my
complimentary remark I'm happy not just
to support and give you a word here but
we can go further if you would like with
your colleagues I'm very strong
supportive civic society and also in the
Czech Republic I'm ready to to pursue it
also in a complete dialogue and I do
apologize that I will have to go and see
my transport files and my III files
later on in the evening thank you thank
you very much for having been here with
us
residents tell ichika thank you so much
[Applause]
and i'm happy to see commissioner katsu
and present Lambert's here with me
because there were two more members of
the committee of regents who wanted to
give a reflection maybe it's a good idea
to listen to them before we pronounce
some conclusions to that to this opening
session with we're talking about michael
schneider state secretary a
representative of the land of
saxony-anhalt to the federal government
and also member of thank you very much I
would have liked to have asked the vice
president of the European Parliament to
be questions but unfortunately he's gone
but I'll try and it's another
opportunity where's the camera where's
the camera who should I look at really
look at the presidents all perhaps the
guests so what I'll try and do is just
say a couple of words at the end of this
session I've been asked to talk about
cohesion policy but haven't got much
time to do that a lot of important
things have been said that's one point
I'd like to emphasize the Commissioner
kept to the discussion that we at the
committee of the region's and you as the
Commissioner for regional policy have
had discussions over the last few years
and they've been very good and they are
proof that the EU can work very
successfully in this area in your area
because many of your proposals were the
outcome of our discussions together that
you mentioned in May we have we came up
with proposals based on experience and
then you have put them forward and you
have picked up on our input so thank you
very much for that
the president of the Commission I would
have liked if it had been possible to
thank him to thank you for having the
draft for the multi-annual financial
framework it already in May it's to come
into effect in 2021 we it needs to be
adopted promptly and if we don't manage
to do this before the European
Parliament elections if we don't adopt
them in the Parliament and in the
European Council then we're going to be
in really tricky waters and I would have
liked to have shared that opinion with
mr. Yunker today
another point cohesion policy is most
definitely one of the most successful
policies of the European Union many
examples have been shown of this today
but cohesion policy has lost a lot of
acceptance in recent years many public
and private beneficiaries have said just
leave it leave all these complicated
funds alone I don't have the admin to
deal with all of these difficult rules
say for years that's why we have put
removing red tape as one of our
priorities commissioner thank you for
taking on board these ideas and your
proposals are really a massive step in
the direction of removing red tape and
the administrative burden but there's
more grist to the mill here miss
millennia myself will at the Committee
of Regents in December put forward some
concrete proposals not just hot air but
concrete proposals to try and help you
in that direction so that further steps
can be taken thank you everyone for
being here today for your courage and in
using structural funds and it's a good
sign for the future
we can be successful with these this
money and we can produce physical
successes for citizens and that brings
me on to the next point being close to
citizens I think this is one of the key
challenges for the European Union at the
present time and for the coming years as
well the president for the Commission
mr. Yonker mentioned the task force for
subsidiarity which he set up at the end
of last year I was one of the members of
this task force and we tabled some very
good proposals in June not just
theoretical construct but practical
proposals that could be implemented
tomorrow
if everyone everybody wanted to do the
State of the Union address did not touch
on these and I was disappointed but he
he made good today by talking about the
outcomes of the task force here so we
need to implement these these out these
outcomes not just leave them on the
paper so that the results are tangible
in regions and local areas that's
another point I want to pick up on with
our opinion we've opened the door
slightly it's slightly ajar behind it
leads the way to be more subsidiarity
and being closer to citizens we need to
kick that door open and I think to do
this we need a follow-up committee a
task force 2 or 2.0 whatever you want to
call it which follows up on many of our
concerns and and develops and further we
have the chance to be closer to citizens
and we should use this opportunity thank
you Thank You mr. Schneider
Marina care Lucia is sitting next to you
she's president of Umbria region and
also come also the committee of reaches
member si Gracia
thank you thank you very much president
thanks commissioner
dear Kareem I think this afternoon is
important even now that there are
members not only of the committee of the
regions but also representatives of
civil society cities and regions even if
they're not members and it's important
to underline the importance in the
challenge on the future of Europe
knowing that the cohesion policy
strengthens and makes more visible to
citizens the importance of having Europe
in cities and regions is not the future
of Europe but it's the future of our
cities and regions over the past 20
years
if regions have changed if cities have
changed it's mainly due to the capacity
to act of the cohesion policy in the
territories and this will be a challenge
for after 2020 and also perhaps about
the trust of Europe and how much Europe
can change the lives and the quality of
lives of people in the territories on
environmental sustainability challenges
regarding employment social integration
education training culture the
environment infrastructures and each of
these single actions often involves
measures and actions that form part of
the cohesion policy and this is why we
have greatly appreciated the fact that
the European Commission has the cohesion
policy for all European regions we think
that this policy is important not only
for regions that are taking their time
to develop but also for everybody
research in competitiveness has to serve
all regions we think that it's dangerous
that those who think in the council to
compare budgets
giving up on the best thing that Europe
has built which is making Europe
cohesive involving the region's we can't
forget part of the cohesion policy we
don't share this change and also there's
that risk of decentralization in certain
countries the cohesion policy is useful
to cities to regions where people live
where they can immediately see concrete
results and they can ask or make local
and regional governments accountable so
we've got to focus on that and I'm
saying that for the entire cohesion
policy but also in particular for the
European Social Fund ESF plus we need to
avoid having a fund that is too focused
to national it's got to be available to
regions to fight against unemployment to
integrate young people in the labor
market it's also got to be available to
work out differences within the
individual regions and we also
appreciated and together with our
colleague mr. Schneider we're preparing
the opinion of the committee of the
regions and we're going to underscore a
number of points we need to do more when
it comes to simplification the more the
cohesion policy is used by companies by
individuals the easier it is to use for
local authorities and people and the
more this will have an impact on the
trust or the faith of citizens and their
realization that Europe is doing
concrete things and also Karina I said
this on behalf of the Socialists but
also I'd like to say something as the
president of my region in the center of
Italy that's been affected greatly by
earthquakes what the Commission has done
for us and what it did for us 20 years
ago as well was really important to us
this year and from 2016 with solidarity
funds mr. young cos not here
it did a number of concrete things when
it came to reconstructing our
communities it provided funds but also
the symbol of Europe reconstruction
doesn't only involve building materials
but it's also social materials and
that's done through Europe and if we
manage to meet this challenge I think
we'll be doing a great job for the
future of Europe but also for the future
of our cities and our regions thank you
[Applause]
the tone has been set it will be looking
a whole week for a balance between
speaking and listening and trying to
keep times up and realizing that we need
a lot of time to talk to each other and
listen to each other so I wish you the
best of luck with that I invite the both
of you of course to have a closing word
before we invite the people to go to the
opening of Agora thank you very much
once again to all of you it has been a
very interesting thats i said and very
important and this second point about
the future of europe it's essential
because you know very well as i said
that in May we submitted to the European
Parliament and the Council of modern
cohesion policies regarding 73 billion
but Europe of course is not only about
money cohesion policy is more than just
investment many has said already here
cohesion policy is solidarity and if I
may if the UN has no one live left
behind in my in my portfolio my motto is
no region left behind so it's very
important for me to all the regions to
benefit for cohesion policy then
bringing Europe browser to the regions
as the region's closer to Europe I saw
so many movies you made here how
cohesion policy is investing in our
future in education innovation did you
skill education employment Social
Inclusion and making differences for so
many millions of people beings Bingham
young or middle-aged or elderly people
so I very much what President Carter
lumber said about what we have to think
every single day is not only what Europe
can do for for us but what we can do for
Europe and to keep these unique projects
that we have on our planet who brought
peace prosperity of course nothing is
perfect we don't return sees that that
is perfect but we cannot live in in
isolation we cannot go back in with
years coping with everything alone of
course we have challenges first of all
we have breaks it the second next the
second biggest contributors is leaving
us it's something very sad we regret it
but its effect we also have challenges
like migration border control security
is for the first time when European
Union is asked to respond and to
contribute to this challenges and even
with these challenges with we we succeed
succeeded to submit these seven three
three three hundred seventy three
billion euro for cohesion policy for the
first time in the history of European
Union is a biggest envelope and with a
red tape
I very much share with you I'm in favor
of radical simplification and you will
see that our proposal which is now in
the hands of European Parliament and the
council are intended to make the life of
beneficiary much more friendly because I
really think that we have to Toto to try
to to be much more on the implementation
set than in doing the papers and
of course we need sir control this is
very important so we're here we are for
this week of discussion hearing into
each other I think it's very important
to work together to achieve Europe's
greatest priorities growth and jobs for
the future of course smarter economies
greener and more inclusive societies and
thank you to all of you I would like to
thank you to the committee of the
regions so all the presidents but
especially the president who was a glue
who took us and brought us together
European Parliament the Commission
Committee of the regions and we wouldn't
have been here with his greatest
achievement in spite of all the
challenges with hours of great
personalities like mr. Lambert and mr.
McCullough with whom I worked very well
and I would like to thank you from the
bottom of my heart thank you very much
thank you very much time is up but
please mr. Lambert no I don't want to
repeat anything I just want to support
what Commissioner cut to and miss
millennia mr. Schneider said cohesion
policy is not a policy of the past
rather a cohesion policy is an important
challenge for the future we should now
put our nose to the grindstone and make
sure that in the 2021 2027 planning
phase we can have a constructive
successful and above all a future
oriented cohesion policy but we all need
to keep working on our projects which is
we now have the opportunity to visit
Agora which is a great opportunity that
they committed the regions will take a
step back and go to our Bureau working
on what we've spoken about here today
and I hope that over the course of the
next few days we'll see each other
so once again and I hope that you'll
give us a lot of inspiration and you'll
take a lot of inspiration from the
events here in Brussels and you can go
back home and continue the valuable work
that you're doing for your station so
all of you also I invite you to join to
the Agora and I wish you a very very
very interesting week and a successful
working together week have a nice day